hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar titled serological and cellular
approaches to kovis 19 research using
flow cytometry this webinar is part of
the 2021 microbiology virtual week and i
am susie valdez of labyrinth and i will
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and sponsored by
luminex for more information about
luminix please go to www.luminexcorp
so let's get started i want to begin by
reminding everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want during this
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
send we'll answer as many questions as
we have time for at the end of our
presentation and if you have any trouble
seeing or hearing this presentation just
click on that ask a question box located
on the far left of your screen
now as a reminder this presentation is
educational and offers free continuing
education credits click on the
continuing education credits tab located
on the top right hand corner of your
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain those credits
i now present today's speaker dr kamala
skyergarjen the director of flow
cytometry assays and application for
complete biography of our speaker please
visit the biography tab at the top of
your screen
dr tiger garden welcome you may now
begin your presentation
good morning everyone welcome to today's
presentation on serological and cellular
approaches to covert 19 research using
flow cytometry
my name is kamla thiagradjan and i'm
director of flow cytometry assays and
applications at luminex corporation
during this presentation
i would like to discuss methods in
covert 19 research especially with
regards to cytoskeletal serology and
cellular assays enabled by flow
cytometry
we will be following the agenda shown in
the slide here for this presentation
we'll start out with discussing covert
19 research needs and the role of flow
cytometry and such research
we will spend the bulk of the talk on
the guava sarskovi ii multi-antigen
antibody as the describing assay
features and its importance and context
of sarskobi to serology
will show several applications of using
the assays for various studies including
those of applications to vaccinated
samples
and then we will spend a short time on
looking at how flow cytometry can enable
cellular as is relevant as kubernetes
research we will then conclude with a
brief summary
in mid-2021 today we stand still worried
amidst the covered 19 pandemic with the
sars kobe 2 virus
continuing to persist and predominate
worldwide this has created an acute need
to assess the immune response and to
develop strategies to monitor tackle and
overcome the disease
numerous publications have shown that
cellular and serological responses are
crucial to understand the nature of the
immune response in both natural
infection and post-vaccination studies
several of these have publications have
shown that flow cytometry is a powerful
technology that can provide the
capability to address many of these
questions
questions and kobe 19 research span a
wide range these include questions on
how does the virus impact the immune
system how does the immune system
respond and how does one bolster the
response with vaccine strategies and
drug discovery approaches to modulate
and eliminate the virus we'll touch upon
some of these areas during our
presentations
techniques such as phenotyping studies
phenotyping of t cells or lymphocytes
subsets
and changes in responses and immune cell
subside or pbmcs and stimulation with
viral antigens
have been really crucial in
understanding the nature of cellular
immunity
similarly
another major area of study is serology
and the development of sarcophagu
specific antibody response to understand
humoral immunity
several researchers are thus interested
in obtaining information on both
cellular and serological aspects in
their investigations
currently many of these studies are
being performed on separate platforms
and technologies that can enable
obtaining both cellular and serological
information on the same platform can
provide a great deal of flexibility and
convenience to researchers
flow stametry is a technology that can
allow one to perform multiparametric
cellular assays as well as b based amino
acids using characteristics of scatter
and fluorescence
luminix provides a range of flow
cytometry platforms that can fit
different needs
these include smaller compact platforms
with customized assays such as the guava
mu cell analyzer shown in the first
column
we also provide
multiparametric platforms such as the
huawei easy side flow cytometer and the
amnes cell stream flow cytometer which
are equipped with multiple lasers and
many detection channels
our advanced systems include the imaging
flow cytometers such as the amnest flow
site and the amnest image stream system
that
combine the power of imaging cytometry
along with flow cytometry to provide
insightful information
the choice of platform can be dictated
by throughput
needed number of parameters that need to
be detected simultaneously budgets and
expertise of personnel available
in the next part of the presentation we
will be mainly focusing on the platforms
based on microcapillary flow cytometry
which is mainly the guava mu cell
analyzer and the
easy side flow cytometer and its
applications to serological research
microcapillary flow psychometry
capillary flow cytometry platforms have
great utility for infectious disease
research
micro capillary cytometry shown on the
left differs from traditional flow
cytometry in on the right in that it
does not utilize sheet fluid the sample
is aspirated directly from a sample tube
or well through a micro capillary flow
cell and it's integrated interrogated by
a laser as it goes in single file
data is collected from the detection
channels as the sample flows through
this when combined with the positive
displacement syringe pump allows for the
determination of absolute counts which
is very useful in many cellular assays
this unique design leads to smaller and
more compact size of instruments and
results in them being
and being able to place them in
convenience locations such as
biological hoods if needed
the technology offers many advantages it
results in the need for reduced sample
sizes and fewer samples
fewer number of cells per analysis this
can be very helpful when only precious
amount of infected samples
may be available
next the system generates low by
hazardous waste and this as you can
imagine is very useful when dealing with
infectious samples but most importantly
these systems also provide absolute cons
without needing to use external beads
which is highly useful in characterizing
immune cell populations or normalizing
cell number
i would like to now go on to discuss a
new assay we have developed for flow
cytometry the guava sars kobe 2
multi-antigen antibody assay and its
applications to cover 19 related
questions
neurological assays have played a
crucial role in coping 19 research
these assays have shed light on the
magnitude and persistence of the immune
response in different studies such as
natural infection epidemiological and
surveillance studies and in the
development of treatment strategies and
development of therapeutic drugs
the assays continue to be important to
study vaccination response in different
sub-populations
and the persistence of response and
different groups with more strategies
such as booster strategies coming in
as people consider different acid types
to the use they should consider if the
assay of choice can provide
comprehensive information
on the different antibodies present in
the samples against different antigens
whether they need isotype specific
response information and if the assay of
choice has a wide dynamic range to span
the entire kind of samples that they are
studying
so what are the key antigens of interest
to people studying sars covetous
antibodies
the sarskopito genome encodes several
proteins and well known among these are
the nucleocapsid protein
the spike protein membrane glycoprotein
and the envelop protein
the nucleocapsid protein is an abundant
and important structural protein of sars
covetovirus this participates in rna
packaging and viral particle release and
is highly immunogenic
antibodies against this protein
indicate exposure to sarcobi2 and anti
and antibodies have been detected with
high specificity in early stages of
infection
the s protein plays a critical role in
viral infection and pathogenesis
and it's a critical target for the
induction of antibodies particularly
neutralizing antibodies
the s protein contains two subunits the
s1 and the s2 subunit
the s1 subunit contains the receptor
binding domains that
mediates the binding of the virus to the
asteroid receptor
people have used multiple forms of the s
protein
the rbd domain the full length s1 plus
s2 a partial s1 domain
for different serological tests
acids
that are targeting
multiple antigens
and fishing for the different antibodies
in parallel can provide a better
understanding of the nature and
magnitude of the antibody response
and this aspect has become particularly
important as
we will discuss in dealing with
vaccinated samples and and also in
dealing with variants so multi-antigen
serology
has become key to providing more
detailed information
on what's going on with their immune
response
multiple antibody isotypes have been
shown to be produced in response to the
sarcopedia virus and plasma and serum
samples
several papers have shown the presence
of igm and iga aesthetics in addition to
the igg isotypes and also establish that
these additional isotopes contribute to
the immune response mechanism and
neutralizing activities
it is important to know that different
isotypes may predominate depending on
the time that has
passed post symptom onset and this can
be seen from the chart on the
left where we can see that the igm and
iga isotypes tend to rise early and then
fade away a bit faster while the igg
isotype rises up a little slower but has
a more sustaining response when we look
at samples at different stages
post-symptom onset
thus tracking the dynamic changes for
the isotap specific response may be
important to understanding the full
spectrum of response
it's also interesting to know that while
there are many assays available today
for igg detection against
sarskopito antigens fewer assays are
available for igm and iga isotypes
and
often
studies are pulling datasets from
different platforms or different assays
to get the information together
which is not ideal
i'd like to next discuss a new essay for
sars coveto antibody detection called
the guava sars kobe 2 multi-antigen
antibody assay
the assay is a bead-based immunoassay
and uses a simple sample prep protocol
followed by acquisition by flow
cytometry
the assay allows for antibody detection
against multiple source covalent
antigens in parallel
and permits the detection of igg
igm and iga antibodies using the same
kit flow cytometry based acquisition and
analysis can be performed either using
the assay on simplified platforms like
the guava mu cell analyzer
or on the guava either side hd platforms
it can also be used on a third-party
instrument
equipped with a blue 480 nanometer or
green 532 nanometer laser
outputs from the assay can be used to
interpret the presence of antibodies in
the sample being studied
the assay kit includes
a microsphere mix
buffers and pe conjugated detectors
against the three isotypes
the multiplex bead acid kit
includes
negative beads and three beads against
the three sarscovito antigens
and the antigens include the n bead
which is conjugated to the nucleocapsid
protein
the rbd bead which is against the
receptor binding domain of the spike
protein and the s1 bead which is
conjugated to the s1 subunit of the
spike protein
the three isotype isotop-specific
detectors are conjugated to be
the protocol is really simple
beads are incubated with diluted sample
and
this is incubated for 30 minutes
uh there's a simple wash step
wherever the supernatant is removed and
then
detectors are added to the sample
followed by a 30 minute incubation
removal of supernatant and then the
sample is ready to read on the
instruments the sample can be prepped in
tubes or plate depending on the platform
of interest
the reagent kit can be used with
multiple cytometers
on the mule cell analyzer platform
there's a sars kobe 2 antibody assay
specific software module and this module
guides the user through specific steps
of data acquisition and interpretations
data outputs include plots and then
median fluorescent intensity information
on the guava eec site 12 hd cytometer
inside software and a settings file can
be utilized to obtain similar results
needed for interpretation
one on third-party cytometers one can
use the typical acquisition software
and set it up for data acquisition and
analysis
thus there's a visual output of results
as well as median fluorescence intensity
data
provided for data interpretation
the slide here shows you examples of
data obtained by analyzing
serum samples on the left and plasma
samples on the right using the guava
sars code 2v2 multi-antigen antibody
assay
for negative samples we observe from the
plots that all four beads line up and
there is no shift of the beads in the
analyte response direction this means
there are no antibodies against
sarscobito antigens present in the
sample
for positive samples
we can notice that there's a shift of
one to three beads
in the analyte response directions
indicating that antibodies against this
particular antigen are present in the
sample
by using the isotype specific detectors
one is able to obtain
information on the presence of igg
igm or iga specific isotype in that
particular sample
we next looked at antibody response
between negative and positive
samples for a larger data set using the
assay
included serum samples from 28 negative
donors who were mainly pre-september
2019
collected samples
the data set also included samples from
27 donors
which were confirmed positive based on
sarscope to molecular or pcr test
results previously
samples were prepped in tubes for
analysis on the mu cell analyzer and the
third-party cytometer and they were
prepped in plates for analysis on the
guava easy inside 12ht system
as you can see in the plots median
intensity information is plotted for
each of the bead populations
for negative
samples we notice that there's little or
no response of the beads minimal
intensity being observed for each of
these beads and this data is shown only
for the new cell analyzer but similar
results were obtained on the other
system
for the positive samples what we notice
is that there is distinct
intensity observed for one two three
antigens
for the different donors that were
studied
and this is seen across the three
systems
so data here
shows us very strongly that we can
cleanly
identify positive from negative donors
and also the same nature of detective
ability can be obtained using the kit
across the different platforms
one can see the igg response also more
visually here response from serum
samples from different donors are shown
the days on top of each sample indicate
when sample is drawn postwar symptom
the data shows that there is response in
samples even starting at six days and
all the way up to 133 days uh in the
sample studied thus in each case we can
see that there is a clear and distinct
shift of populations being observed and
identification of the samples as being
positive by the assay
we next looked at antibody response in
samples collected from different
positive donors at different periods of
time post symptom onset
two sample types were studied one said
included 14 donors which were collected
within 14 days of symptom
the second set included about 20 donors
and these were positive and collected at
greater than 14 days post symptom onset
as one can see in this plot of the
intensity for these beat sets
we notice that in almost all samples
show good response where antibodies
against multiple antigens with this
assay interestingly response can be
seen in several donors less than 14 days
allowing for antibody detection
and all donors greater than 14 days show
response from two or more antigens
the high sensitivity from flow cytometry
might thus allow for earlier and
clear-cut identification of the presence
of these antibodies
we also looked at the presence of
antibody isotypes in the larger sample
pool
here we show results from detection of
igg ign and iga isotypes
in positive samples that were positive
by molecular test results and comparing
that response with pre-september 2019
negative samples
while it's not surprising to see igg
reactivity as shown in the first plot
for a large number of samples it's
interesting to note
that there are a substantial number of
samples which show ign and iga isotypes
against the different antigens in
particular samples
thus the study of
isotype presence is very significant
in
understanding the complete nature of the
immune response so we don't miss out
understanding
the significance of the effects
one can see these effects more visually
for antibody isotope detection
in a range of samples from 43 to 260
days
and what one notices is that while we
see igg antibodies against the different
antigens
over the full span of samples that we
are observing
igm and iga antibodies are observed in
fewer samples and this declines as the
sample ages
let's take a look at why looking at
antibody isotypes may be important in
different studies
here we show an example
of donors
at multiple duration post-first symptom
donor one which is five days post
symptom onset
shows the presence of igg antibodies
against the nucleocapsid antigen
but but what is really striking is that
this donor shows very high levels of an
igm antibodies
against the rbd antigen
it also shows the presence of an iga
antibody against the nucleocapsid
protein
and it's interesting to note that this
particular
sample
showed very high neutralizing activity
in an in-vitro
viral neutralization assay
donor two is another kind of sample
where
the donor is 13 days for symptom onset
and samples from this donor were
analyzed with the assay and what we
notice is that
there appears to be good levels of igg
igm and iga isotypes all present in this
particular sample
if we look at another donor donor 3
which is 124 days for symptom onset we
notice that this sample is predominantly
all igg
and there's negligible amounts of igm
and iga antibodies presence against any
of the antigens
and this is in line with our
understanding of the decline of igm and
iga isotypes
as these samples age
plus depending on age of sample and
status different antibody isotypes could
predominate and they may be very
important in drawing conclusions about
sample sets
one can also use the assay to study the
development of the isotype response
over
different days for the same donor that
is application to longitudinal studies
over here we have the same donor who is
positive by qcr for sarcobito infection
and sample was collected over multiple
days
from nine to fifty nine days from the
donor
the samples were then acid using the
guava sar scorpio multi-antigen antibody
assay
and run on the easy side 12 hd system
the heat map features
of the inside software gives you a very
nice visual display
about the different levels of each of
the antibodies against the three
antigens for each of the different
isotypes and this allows you to get a
quick visual feel for how
the the isotype levels are one can also
look at this data graphically and for
simplicity the the data
for the n antigen is shown
in the plots on the right
as you can see in these plots you can
see that the igg response shows a more
classic profile and a sustaining
the igm and iga beads show response and
presence of these antibodies
in earlier time frames which then tend
to taper off as time progresses
later as this can be conveniently
followed by the kit and analyzed by flow
cytometry
i would like to now move on to the
applications of the assay to vaccinated
samples
as the world intensifies its efforts on
vaccination strategies serological
assets continue to play an increasingly
important role
anthocyanin to antibody assays can eat
not only the development of the vaccine
itself but also in determining the long
lasting impact
the vaccine strategies today include dna
or mrna coding for the source kobe 2
spike protein
they also include
protein or peptide based approaches from
the sar scovi 2 proteins
or they include engineered viruses that
is viral vectors expressing for example
the spike protein there are also classic
approaches like using inactivated or
weakened sars kobe 2 virus
so as people choose the best assay to
study samples from vaccinated donors the
need to look at the vaccine type and the
antigens to which they would expect to
see an antibody response
for example some of the mrna based
vaccination strategies are against the
spike protein or the receptor binding
domain of the spike protein
and this will give rise to antibodies
against these proteins
but these tests will be missed by a
antibody test that is based on the
nucleocapsid
protein from the sarcopte virus
for strategies such as inactivated or
viking virus one would expect to see
responses against
the nuclear capsid protein spike and rbd
protein so one really needs to
understand
what vaccine
was given to a donor
and what is the expected response
one also needs to make sure that the
assay of choice has a dynamic range
which can detect
samples
from early infection to high level of
antibodies which can be observed in some
vaccinated donors
so what are some of the questions of
interest in the study of vaccinated
samples
several studies have used their logical
assays to look at sample typing research
and confirm the immune response and
presence of expected antibodies on
vaccination
the capability to distinguish between
vaccinated samples versus naturally
infected samples has become very
important in understanding
and monitoring breakthrough infections
another crucial area of study is
elucidating immune response differences
in different immunocompromised subgroups
this includes individuals with cancer
transplant recipients people with
autoimmune diseases and people on
immunosuppressant drugs
in many of these studies
elucidating the duration persistence
and response
is very important to understand general
trends
these studies are also very important in
illuminating requirements or needs for
future vaccination or booster shots
here we show examples of applications of
the assay to serum samples from
vaccinated donors
donors include people
who have had either pfizer or modern
vaccines as indicated
the upper plot shows the igg response
the middle set of plots represents the
igm response and the third set of plots
represents the iga response in these
samples
the plots immediately show the presence
of
igg antibodies against rbd
and s1 antigens across the different
donors which is what we would expect to
see
even visually one can note that there is
varying levels of antibodies one can
observe between the different donors
the donors do not show
any presence of igm antibodies
but several donors showed the additional
presence of iga antibodies against the
rbd and s1 antigens
we next studied the antibody response in
samples that we obtained from jnj
vaccinated donors
in the few samples we studied we notice
that while a couple of the donors had
the expected response again the s1
and rbd protein as would be expected
with this kind of vaccine
one of the donors had
no igg igm or iga levels
and it was interesting to note that this
non-responsive donor
had an autoimmune condition
the multiplex multi-antigen antibody
assay
can be very helpful in identifying
donors that might have had previous
infection
in the example plots here for the fisa
vaccinated and moderna vaccinated donors
in addition to the rbd and the s1 bead
response we would have expected to see
we are also seeing a response of the n
bead indicating antibodies against the
nucleocapsid protein
are present in these samples
and this is indicative of the fact that
these donors might have had natural
infection
due to which we are seeing antibodies
against the nucleocapsid antigen
these kind of multiplex antibody assays
can thus help distinguish between a
vaccinated uninfected sample
and samples with suspected natural
infections for certain vaccination types
that are against the
spike or
rbd proteins
the figure here shows the median
fluorescence intensity response
using the guava sars kobe 2 multi
antigen antibody assay on non-vaccinated
and vaccinated donors
the first set of plots here is from
infected donors
which are non-vaccinated and what we
notice here is that we see good response
from the n bead the rbd and the s1 bead
for most of these donors
if we look at the physio vaccinated
samples we see there is strong rbd and
s1 response in most donors
but a donor or two has end response in
the sample tested which indicates a
likely prior infection
we can also see a donor with low
intensity of signal for the rbd or s1
response
on the madonna samples too we see a
strong rbd and s1 response and the
presence of at least one donor who
appears to be previously infected
thus we see a spread of igg responses
from donors
not all donors showing
high intensity
one can also study trends in antibody
development before and after first and
second shot of vaccination
in this study here we evaluated a few
donors
where we had samples from before
vaccination after the first vaccine and
after the second vaccine
as we see in the plots from these donors
there's different trends in igg response
on vaccination after the first and
second doses
but we do see that there is a boost
which is achieved after the second
vaccine
it also seems like the levels of igg
produced between the different donors
are also very different
this kind of data can be compared in the
plots
as shown in this figure
where the plots show the response
from each donor
for antibodies against each particular
antigen in the vaccination studies
we notice in each case that the rbd
response is dominant and is boosted
significantly
with the second shot
studies such as this in larger donor
pools might provide a more complete
picture of the trends on what's going on
with regard to the immune
response in these kind of different
sample types
i would like to next take a few minutes
and switch to discussing how flow
cytometry can provide answers relevant
to covet 19 research for cellular
questions
as we discussed earlier
covert 19 research can often require
quick screening of blood and pvmc
samples to obtain characterization and
enumeration of subpopulations
flow cytometry platforms that can
provide absolute count information
economically are very useful for the id
and enumeration of whole blood or pbmc
samples
those assays such as the count and
viability assay or immunology assays on
microcapillary platform can provide
answers using very low amount of samples
using assay specific templates
the counted mobility assay uses a
pre-formulated mix of membrane
penetrating and non-penetrating dyes and
this allows for the sensitive detection
of nucleated cells
dead cells and debris
and thus in the sample when mixed with
the cellular sample it can provide
distinction of viable cells from debris
and distinction of dead cells from
viable cells using very small quantities
of sample
similarly the muse
immunology assays are mix and read asses
that can provide information on
different immune cell populations in
whole blood or pbmc samples very easily
and quickly
closed captioning not
cell types available
fresh and frozen pbmc samples
the assay has a
dedicated software module that outputs
summarized data in an easy to interpret
format as shown in this figure
the cell concentration outputs from the
assay have been compared to predicate
methods
for fresh pvmcs frozen pbmcs and
multiple concentrations
and as you can see on this plot here
that you're seeing very nice
correlations between the different
methods
precision of the assay has also been
studied
and not only for pbmcs but also for
other cell lines and typically what we
observed is that you can obtain a
percent cb of less than 10 percent for
cell concentration and viability results
and thus this assay can be of great
utility uh in looking at viability or
concentrations of cellular samples that
might be
important especially if people are uh
you know preparing the samples for
immune response studies or prescreening
the samples and deciding whether it's
good to go to the next experiment
absolute counts and percentages of t and
b cells have shown to be very important
in the phenotyping of cov19 samples and
cd4 and cd8 t cells in particular have
been shown to undergo significant
reduction with the severity of the
disease
capturing this information for all
samples can be very important
and meals immunology assays can provide
absolute counts of cd4 and cd8 t cells
total lymphocyte counts and percentage
of population using only 10 microliter
of blood
example of cd4 t cell and cd8 t cell is
shown in this figure over here
dot plots show the results for the cd4 t
cell for example here where we can see
the upper
two populations represent the total
lymphocytes and the upper right
population represents the cd4 t cell
population
similarly for cd8 the upper right
represents the cda t cell and the total
upper population represents total
lymphocyte and this is utilized to
obtain information on absolute count of
the t cell
total lymphocyte count and percentage
as a percent of total lymphocytes
on the right here we show comparison of
the cd4 t cell absolute khans from muse
using microcapillary cytometry against
higher end flow platforms and as we look
at this figure we see that across a wide
range of measurements we are seeing
really nice correspondence of results
we've also looked at precision
on these assays
here is results from looking at three
operators on three instruments running
four samples and triplicates and as we
look at the percent cvs in these
measurements we see typically that we
obtain a percent cv of less than 10 for
a lot of these studies
thus the simple no wash protocol
and easy to use instrument with micro
capillary psychometry can really enable
one to quickly obtain
enumeration information on tnb cell
populations
one can also obtain more detailed
studies and obtain enumeration
information on multiple subpopulations
in parallel
here we show multiparametric analysis
for tb and k populations using flow
cytometry
example is shown for cd checks plus on
the top and cd checks low controls
stained with combinations of cd45
cd3
cd4 cd8 cd19 and cd56 and cd16
antibodies and most of these antibodies
are each conjugated a different
fluorophore and so can be looked at in
different channels
the data can be easily mined to obtain
count and percentage of each of these
populations
and
they can be then compared
with other
methods or other data that you've
obtained here for example we have
compared the results obtained to those
provided by the vendor
as shown in the plots on the right as
you can see in this graphs here
the the results from the user's sidewall
hd are in blue and the vendor results
and the limits are in different colors
and as you can see from the data of the
absolute count information for the
various subpopulation in both sample
types as well within limits provided by
the vendor
data such as this which can be obtained
in 10 microliters of blood uh it can be
very useful
and especially because you can perform
these assays in a no wash format in
either tubes or plates
one can take this further to obtain more
detailed information on knife and memory
t-cell populations
here fresh whole blood was stained with
different combinations of antibodies in
a known wash format and analyzed by
microcapillary flow psychometry
in addition to being able to dissect t
cells
one can see the b cells and k cells and
further one can subdivide the cd4 and
cd8 t cells
into
knive and memory sub populations using
additional antibodies in the mix
this information can also be obtained
with 10 microliters of blood and these
kind of phenotyping studies can thus be
very useful in studying different donors
and much greater detail
to summarize my presentation today
we discussed that cobin 19 research
requires the evaluation of a wide range
of cellular and serological parameters
and these methods can be enabled by flow
cytometry
we also discussed that serological
studies continue to be important for
understanding coping 19 related immune
response
its sustenance and the post-vaccination
response
we showed you information on the guava
sarskovi to multi-antigen antibody assay
and describe that it's a new
multi-antigen bead-based acid for flow
cytometry that can provide a complete
picture of antibodies against multiple
sarcobito antigens the targets include
nucleocapsid protein rbd and spike s1
protein
igg igm and iga antibodies against all
these proteins can be detected with
using the same kit
and the assay is a universal assay which
can be utilized on platforms like the
guava mu cell analyzer the guava easy
side systems as well as other flow
cytometers
we hope that with this increased
capability the combined information from
cellular and antibody characteristics on
the same flow cytometry platforms can
enhance and empower cover 19 research
and finally i would like to acknowledge
all team members and colleagues who
contributed to this work
the bulk of the data presented was
generated by kim van praan and julie
khloe
my thanks to my r d and marketing team
members who contributed to multiple
aspects of this project
and finally my thanks to the audience
for the attention
thank you
thank you kamala for your informative
presentation we will now start the q a
portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
let's get started
all right our first question
kamala is the information on isotopes
important when studying vaccinated
samples and what what role do these
isotopes play
thank you for the question and thank you
everybody for attending uh today's
webinar
so when you're looking at
source code infection natural infection
numerous studies have shown
that the different isotypes igp igm and
iga
are observed in serum and plasma samples
and and they play a very important role
in neutralizing activity for example
in vaccinated samples too studies are
showing uh in particular the presence of
iga
antibodies too several studies have
demonstrated that
and uh in fact some recent studies have
also shown the presence of iga not only
in serum but also in
a milk secretion they have shown in
shown that in mucosal
uh pathways so so
the isotypes are present and because
they contribute to the immunity in the
natural infection it's expected that
these antibody isotypes also
contribute to the neutralizing activity
that we see
even from the
vaccinated samples so this has become a
very important area of study where
information is still being gathered
because men you know
because uh
vaccination and then looking at the
samples and details are still newer
and um
and the answer type
and what do
how do they
really build up and contribute to that
resistance
and the immune response is still to be
understood
thank you
thank you next question we have here
what are the advantages in flow
cytometry over other methods for sars
kobe 2 serology
that's a good very good question there
are numerous methods for serology and
each of them has their own advantage
but flow cytometry provides certain
unique advantages
for um the biggest advantage you can get
by doing the assay by serology i say by
flow cytometry for example like we have
shown
is that you can take advantage of the
multiplexing that you can get with a
flow cytometry
you know you're able to look at multiple
response to multiple antigens in
parallel so there's a lot more
information that you're getting per
experiment
or per
run per assay that is run on the
circometer
secondly you have fluorescence detection
and many other methods for serology use
calorimetric methods uh for example
and these have lower some tend to have
lower sensitivity but
with
fluoresce with flow cytometry you get
the advantage of the high sensitivity
that can come from fluorescent detection
and that results in actually the
advantages of being able to detect
samples early on and it also
and also comes with a broad dynamic
range that is really important to look
at natural infection versus and as well
as vaccinated samples
so um
the third kind of advantage you have in
how we have the assay structured
especially by flow cytometry is that um
many other methods require you to run
plates or place those samples so
um so you need to so depending if you
had fewer samples you may have to
sacrifice certain
um
or certain uh your spots in your plate
but um in a flow cytometry if you had a
fewer samples you could run this in
tubes or you could run it in plates it
just depends on
what your throughput may be or how it
varies from day to day so certainly very
distinct advantages with flow
but the also another crucial example is
that a lot of people who are doing these
kind of assays are also interested in in
cellular immunity in addition to immoral
immunity
and a lot of those assays get run on
flow cytometers and now by having um
being having this capability to run
covet 19 serology and flow cytometry
they're able to do both their immoral
and immunity studies as well as cellular
immunity related studies on the same
platform
thank you for that informative answer
um our next question we have here why is
serology still so important in a
post-vaccine world
that's a very good question and in fact
the importance of serology keeps getting
more and more
important uh you know with vaccination
what people are looking for is what's
the immune response do we have are we do
we have the antibodies present in it
which are which many of which have
studies have established can
fight off infection or severe infection
right
so um with vaccines you know people are
interested in understanding a is there
is there that immune response then what
is the duration how long do these
antibodies stay on do they go down do
they need to be
uh get booster shots so all of these
kind of answers are aided by serological
assays
the other kind of information that you
can get is
with relation to
particular subgroups now numerous
studies
in the past several months have
established that
um certain subgroups uh
of people who maybe you know who have
had maybe kidney transplant cancer
or be on
immunosuppressive drugs
many of these
people have had reduced
or sometimes no level of antibodies and
this is
again extremely important to understand
um
what is what is their immune reaction
especially with regard to antibody
production is on vaccination and what
kind of strategies do we need to develop
so that we can bolster that response for
uh
for all people
um
and uh and you know there may be
particular treatments needed in certain
cases uh
for these kind of subpopulation so what
strategies will work better for them
so so there are a lot of open questions
still and i think serology plays a very
crucial role
in
trying to gather information and answer
some of these questions which
will help us with tackling the var uh
the kovin-19 and the virus itself
thank you it looks like we have time for
one more question
what is the utility of screening against
multiple antigens approach for sars kobe
2 serology
well that's a good question um
as we saw in the talk we had examples of
a multi-antigen approach
and if you look at it
what it really tells us is it gives us
information on the full spectrum
or on a more comprehensive spectrum of
antibodies that are present
in a sample that you study
uh but
in addition there is also this um
these scenarios where for example if
there was
someone who was um
who has not been had the uh coven 19 but
they had a vaccination especially with
anything
any vaccine strategies that related to
the spike protein then we can see in
those cases that we only see
antibodies related to the spike or the
receptor binding domain protein coming
up so
now if these people had natural
infection or
were you know were having natural
infection at the time
um samples were taken from them
you would see
also the nucleocapsid protein response
antibodies against the nucleocapsid
protein come up
so
so the having multiple antigens this
allows you to
learn a little bit more about the full
spectrum of antibodies as well as
distinguish certain scenarios
like uh in this case um
vaccination strategies with spike
proteins and probably without
infection
thank you so much kamala for your time
today and your important research before
we go i'd also like to thank the
audience for joining us today and their
interesting questions
and also our sponsor luminex for
sponsoring today's webinar
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand for
two years until september 9th of 2023
and labyrinths will alert you via email
when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time thank
you so much again kamala goodbye
thank you everyone